what's up guys so as we all know all pcs
yes CPU cool there's always been two
major ways to cool a CPU air or liquid
e-liquid has always been known to be the
superior method of cooling but also came
with a lot of work
maintenance risk or leaking and
especially a lot more money just for a
few degrees for lower temperatures or a
few hundred million megahertz of higher
clock speed corsair and many other
companies have been trying to give the
consumers a mid range option that wasn't
as expensive as a full liquid loop but
offered similar cooling potential these
are now known as ail coolers and today
I'm going to be taking a look at one of
the most popular ail coolers the courser
H 100 I v2 so let's take a look at the
features that it offers what
overclocking Headroom it provides and
see if it's actually worth it
first of all the Corsair h 100 IV - it's
a 240 millimeter liquid cooler which
comes with to 120 millimeters static
pressure pins the tubes are covered in
ice leaving you only need one fan header
in order to use this cooler great as the
cool it has a splitter built-in which
powers two fins however if you want to
monitor the thermals or play with the
RGB LED then you also need to plug in
the cable which connects onto a USB 2
header on your motherboard this allows
you to monitor fan speeds along with
thermals and even sets of the RGB LED on
the front changes to a different color
if the temperatures XT a certain point
the cooler comes with the Intel bracket
which makes it nice for Intel builders
also for all you rise and those out
there make sure to get the a.m. for
bracket from Corsair if you're h100 IV
to didn't already come with it
the newer shipments should come with it
but if you didn't then make sure to
order that from free from Coursera
mounting the waterblock is very easy
there are just 4 screws that you screw
into the backplate however mounting the
radiator is quite a hassle because a
tubing is quite thick so it is hard to
manipulate the tubing to your favorite
also once I originally installed a
radiator I noticed a little rattling and
so I had to go back and place some
spaces in the screws in order to stop
the radley also the fans aren't the
easiest to screw on so you guys should
consider putting the fans on to raid
here before you guys found the radiator
inside the case there are two cables
coming off the CPU cooler so it's not
easy to hide all the cables completely
out of sight but you can tie them up and
make them as tidy as possible
so that's the features of the cooler now
let's discuss how it performs I have it
Intel i7 8700 K install on that PC I was
able to overclock it to 5 gigahertz
using this cooler and idle my
temperatures are in the low to mid 30s
under full load and my temperatures are
in the low to mid 80s which are in my ok
opinion ok as long as they don't go into
90 there they rarely go into 90s so
that's to find ask for sound the pump
doesn't make any noticeable sound and
the only sound being produced is the
sound from the fence I have 8 pins
inside my case and that's dope quite
quiet I think this time being produced
from this AIO is quite minimal overall
performance from this cooler is
absolutely stunning and it does justify
its price point of 110 dollars as a
result the cooler definitely delivers at
its asking price grades it has a strong
performance nice sleeving
good quality materials and even has some
clever utilization of RGB this cooler is
actually a lot cheaper than other
I'm made by big companies like many XTS
x52 kraken which cost a hundred and
fifty dollars but the real question
isn't if the coolest price is justified
the question is is the extra performance
this cool applies when compared to
cheaper coolers worth it and
unfortunately like my answer to all
premium products unfortunately it is not
worth spending around 50 plus dollars
more than many very good air coolers
like the hyper 212 Evo who provide
nearly identical performance the extra
200 megahertz the cool RGB the sleeker
look and possibly even the choir sound
is not really worth spending three times
that more with that money you guys could
maybe upgrade in GPU level or get more
storage for your SSD or hard drive or
even buy more games or even upgrade to
nvme overall the minimal performance
increase of this provides it's not worth
spending that much more money if you
guys are building a premium build and
only want the best parts available then
this is a good buy and it is after level
of quality that you guys expect from a
puller price of this range this does
really perform really well however if
you guys are considering this cooler
because you guys hope that Allah
increase your cpu performance by 10% or
increase your FPS by 20 frames and
that's really not going to happen so you
guys should just save your money and buy
something that will actually improve
performance by a lot like a SSD or a GPU
upgrade overall this CPU cooler can
taste a range of diminishing returns and
I would recommend that you guys spend
your money on other parts that give more
performance before considering this
cooler if you guys already have a
premium build and just want to know how
this cooler is then this cooler is
absolutely awesome as the great
performance and it really is a top of
the line product if that's you guys want
then you guys should definitely buy this
but otherwise you guys should save your
money and buy something cheaper and
where it actually matters well guys
that's all I have for you guys today if
you guys like studio make sure to toss
me that like if you guys loved it and
would like to see more videos just like
this make sure to subscribe and press
that Bell notification so you guys are
notified every time I post a video okay
guys I would love to hear your comments
about this cooler so make sure to post
on the comments down below
that's all for now guys and until next
video bye